وهنا مشاهدينا نعود بالزمن الى حرب
الخنادق اما في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
فهناك تشابه اخر فكره البحث عن غنائم امرا
طبيعي في الحروب لكن الحربين تشابه في
اصلاح هذه الغنائم والاستفاده منها على
ارض المعركه مجددا في اكتوبر الماضي مثلا
اقدرت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان اكثر من
نصف اسطول الدبابات الاوكرانيه يتكون من
مركبات روسيه تم الاستلاء عليها فعلى
البريطانيون الشيء نفسه بعد معركه العلمين
علم الحميميه وجد الحلفاء على الفور اكثر
من مليون حاويات بترول المانيا واكثر من
50 الف بندقيه وثلاثه الاف رشاش اصلاحها
واستخدمها في معركهم لكن اني ماذا استخدام
الاليات القديمه رغم امكانيات التطور
التكنولوجي الحالي للاسلحه والمعده
المفترض ان يتم
الفرق
الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه بشكلنا متزامنه
اي تنسيق لها جماعه اسلحه المشاه المدرعات
المدفعيه والمهندسين والطيران القدرات
المشتركه الاخرى بشكل فعال في مهمه واحده
امرنا فشلت موسكو وكيف في تحقيقه بشكل
كبير مثلا لم يتلقى الجنود الروس واجزاء
من انظمه ازار للاتصالات للوحدات الموجوده
على الارض الحصول على المنظومه كامله فقط
يضمن الفاعليه وبالتالي لجات روسيا لاجهزه
صينيه تجاريه زهيده الثمن وخرائط صمم قبل
عقود ذلك بحسب واشنطن بوست وير تايمز لكن
على عكس موسكو نجحت ولو ونسميا في ربط
البيانات والمعلومات والاستخباراتيه
ودمجها وتحليلها
على سبيل المثال جمعت المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه من مصادر مفتوحه مثل حسابات
المجندين على مناصات الوسائل وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتحديد مواقع التشكيلات
العسكريه للخصم